I'm getting a sample of one of those patches that people are selling these days.
Is this something that you could muscle test for me?
Do you think if it does good, does test good for me, will it alter the other supplements
in my program?
So there's these little patches, maybe some of you guys are using these frequency patches.
I don't know how many companies sell them now.
It used to be a multi-level company that came out with them.
I don't know, it was a long time ago, probably 10 years ago.
And they were a big fan for a while and they're supposed to give you,
you could get the energy patch or the detox patch or the glutathione patch or
the dispatch or the vial patch or whatever.
They're supposed to have the frequency of that thing that they're trying to do
embedded in it and it was then supposed to help you.
Now, I've had patients that swear by them and say,
I'd use the energy patch and that really helped with my energy.
And hey, who might say that that doesn't work, you know, whatever?
I would just say be really careful because there's all sorts of companies
that are supplement companies, that are therapy companies, that are these type of
companies that they have zero liability for lying through their teeth.
So I would just be careful with those things.
Can't it be helpful for someone?
Baby, good as eggs.
I mean, literally I could bustle test you on probably 100 supplements
that could be helpful for you.
Is it wise to take them all?
No, you have to cherry pick what's going to be the best thing.
So when I'm doing pedisiology on you,
honestly, the chance of those patches helping you with the type of
pedisiology that I'm going to add to your cheek swab is almost next to zero
because I'm locking into cancer.
So I'm not just doing pedisiology for general welfare for you.
I'm doing it specifically for cancer.
So the chance that those are going to help for cancer is probably pretty slim.
Certainly, you can say a sample I could check, but I'm just saying that that's
probably pretty slim.
You know, there's, you know, there are not frequencies for that.
So, but I'm not against using them if you feel like you want to use them.
But I know I've seen different videos out there.
People say, you know, they're obviously somebody who's, you know,
some monkey muck in the company that's making some claim that,
oh, I started using these.
And oh, I don't have to take my supplements anymore because this,
this, you know, changed my DNA or, you know, changed my metabolism.
Now I don't have to do this and now I don't have to do this.
I mean, there's all sorts of gimmicky stuff out there, you know,
from energy to weight loss to this or that.
And you just have to be wise in everything you're doing, that, you know,
there's a lot of current days,
they could stay cool, they'll salesman.
Even in people that have, I mean, it's sometimes it's worse that when people have
MD degrees and stuff, they know, they're trying to get into the natural realm
and they literally don't just, I do think about nutrition.
But since they have an MD and they could use that to their advantage,
they can pretend that they're extremely knowledgeable and they can
push different products that are very good.
So I'm not saying all of them are like that, but you just have to be careful
with, with, with everything, you know, this is what I've shared with you guys
before about this, you know, the positives, the negatives of the internet,
the positives, the negatives of Instagram and Facebook is, you know,
there's a lot of information that you could glean and learn from and
knowledge that you could glean, but there's a lot of false stuff out there as well.
You know, I have people sending me Instagram videos all the time asking me,
what do you think about this?
And you watch it and it's like, you know, some of it is all, that's,
that's great, you know, there's good information, but, you know,
the majority of it is just like, you got to be kidding.
You know, they're just doing things to get followers, to get something,
to sell you something.
And that's the, you just have to look at everybody's bias and,
and my bias as well, you look at everybody's bias.
And then you weigh it out with logic and, and, and, and use reasoning.
The Bible says come, reasoning together with me.
That's why I love the truth of Christianity and biblical wisdom because
you can reason with it.
It's reasonable.
You can work through it.
You don't have to, you know, have this blind faith.
You're having faith in a real God who loves us and wants to take care of us.
And he tells us over and over again that we're not supposed to be ignorant.
And he desires us to be wise and knowledgeable.
And that's, you know, where we should be spending most of our time learning.